[Music]
hotline Miami - wrong numbers action is
so loud and so intense that upon hitting
the pause button reality feels like it's
playing at half speed this is the type
of experience that invites you in to sit
closer to the screen and crank up the
volume higher than usual one of the
lingering memories of the first game was
its heart pounding techno soundtrack so
yeah allow me to get this edit away
early the music and hotline Miami -
wrong number is absolutely outstanding
but to revel in this game slick style
too much would be a disservice to its
ferociously entertaining and challenging
top-down action this is a confident
follow-up which approves upon the
original in almost every conceivable way
hotline Miami - is more varied better
paced and more challenging this is a
tremendously stylish game which
entertains throughout and delights in
forcing you out of your comfort zone
[Music]
[Music]
hotline Miami - wrong number is a
top-down twitch shooter in which you
play a host of psychopaths for an
assortment of reasons are required to
enter various buildings and kill
everyone therein they achieve this using
a variety of weapons shotguns automatic
rifles silenced pistols and even their
fists but regardless of the delivery
methods death comes quickly don't expect
to soak up damage or pick up health
packs here this is a game where a single
bullets can kill you and your foes we're
on the toes tactics and a quick trigger
finger can be the difference between you
completing a level and topping order to
respawn over and over and over how you
choose to clear each area in the game's
30 or so levels is largely up to you you
can run and gun with reckless abandon or
say use a loud shotgun burst to learn
nearby enemies into your path whatever
you choose the engagements are
exhilarating though planning your attack
will net the best results the intense
visuals thumping soundtrack and score
multiplier will seduce you into risking
it all for one glorious foolhardy charge
clever level design and increased enemy
variety make these engagements more
interesting than before halls and rooms
have more interesting angles extra
windows more open areas and multiple
lanes for enemies to approach from what
better enemy placement creates increased
diversity in the types of engagements
you'll encounter the melee resistant
dogs return as did the fad enemies which
are impervious to anything other than
bullets but they're joined by a bullet
docking Samurai running enemies who leap
to close the distance and a selection of
level specific mini bosses in fact
variety is what hotline Miami 2 is all
about while the first game was largely
centered around one single mask swapping
protagonist massacring operations run by
the Russian mob
hotline Miami - wrong number darts back
and forth between dozens of characters
and locations this constantly shifting
pace and variety and as hotline Miami -
to be more restrictive in other ways
though you can sometimes choose from a
small selection of weapons or characters
before a level for the most part you're
forced to play the character as the
story sees fit no longer can you choose
the Tony the Tiger mask to silently take
people in every single level instead the
game encourages you to get better at
shooting by forcing you to play as more
run-and-gun characters
[Music]
and what to say about the story well for
one there's a lot more of it the
original game intentionally obfuscated
what was going on behind an unreliable
narrator and secret endings and much of
that continues here callbacks to the
first game ships in perspective along
with furious timeline swapping means
that all of this reads a lot better on a
second playthrough but truly the story
just plays its part in creating a
surreal experience that's best enjoyed
by letting it wash over you hotline
Miami 2 is a challenging often difficult
game but playing through its various
levels is so enjoyable that dying rarely
feels like it's a punishment the game's
grading system gives you an excuse to
return to levels but it's style is an
even more inviting reason to play again
and again the experience is so audio
visually seductive that you'll find
yourself for playing zones just for the
sake of it
the soundtrack sees returning artists
such as perturbator and jasper byrne
supplying a breath of synth and techno
tracks alongside a host of new musicians
and not only is this music as
exceptional as the first game but
there's also a lot more of it in fact
there's a lot more of everything in this
game I completed the original hotline
Miami in about three hours but by the
time the credits had rolled in hot la
Miami too had registered almost 9:00 and
this was before I'd started over with
the unlockable hard mode before I toyed
around at the games level editor which
is currently in the alpha testing stage
in almost every way hotline Miami 2 is a
marked improvement on an already
tremendous formula this is a game that
had me pumping my fists and laughing
with joy throughout my time with it and
I was left despondent by the time it
drew to a close a gutsy refine game that
isn't scared to force you into corners
and watch you battle out of them and an
audio-visual experience that marries
graphics music and designed so well that
even the pause menu is a work of art
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you